- I'm noticing the dog fur, the dog treats
and the dog bowls but I don't see the dog.
- He died unexpectedly in January.
- So that was your companion?
- Oh yes took him everywhere.
- Yeah, aw.
- Yeah, took him everywhere.
Why have you still kept
the bowl and things?
- Good question.
I don't know.
I should get rid of that.
- Still kinda grieving the loss of him?
- I guess, kinda sorta, yeah.
- Makes sense.
That makes sense, yeah.
- I don't know if you've
noticed where we are?
- Oh my gosh.
Oh this is cool.
- Right?
- Oh look at this.
- [Staff] Hello
- Hi
- I too understand what it
is to lose a baby puppers.
So do you.
- We really wanted to help
Kenny Ken adopt a puppers.
- This is where I got my kittens from.
- We were here a week ago.
- She literally helped me adopt my babies.
- There ya go.
- And so we wanted to bring you here
and see if you tres fell in love.
- Wow.
- Let's just take a walk.
- Let's do it.
- Yeah, we're gonna be open-minded.
- All right.
- Couple little bulldogs.
- Aw. We love you.
- I know.
And then we're gonna
keep going back over here
So, Duchess, this preciousness.
- Oh my gosh
- This little angel of love.
This guy is all things preciousness,
and he's like a hound-ish,
but he's real cute.
These guys are actually siblings,
they're kinda mixed- breed.
- Oh okay.
- So we don't know exactly
what they'll look like
when they grow up but they
kinda look a little bull-y.
- So it's kinda like a surprise,
you don't really know what
they're gonna look like-
- Yeah you really don't!
- it's like an adventure.
- Ribbon hey.
- Margaret's a little shepherd mix
and she's about nine.
And Kramer, is about three.
- They good with other people?
- He's been really
friendly with people here,
sometimes he's a little bit shy.
- And this is what you have,
this is pretty much the selection?
(dogs barking excitedly)
- This is it up here, yep.
I think Akio over there, he's handsome.
- Oh my God.
- And then,
we land on Akio.
- Akio. Oh.
- He's very cute. I know.
- Oh.
- Akio is my favorite sir.
He's a little chow mix,
and he has a gorgeous purple tongue.
He came in as a stray and
he was like skin and bones
and he had practically no hair.
And so, now like, he's
getting a lot better,
and he's on some antibiotics for it
and he's been really
social with other dogs too.
- He reminds me a lot like my last dog,
I had a yellow lab, just like this
- Oh my gosh
- I grew up with yellow labs too
- Really?
- Yeah, her name was Ginny.
- You wanna go for a walk?
- Okay, do you guys wanna head out front
and I'll meet you out there.
(dogs barking intermittently)
- I'm overwhelmed, I wanna cry.
- It's okay.
- He reminds me of my best dog, yeah,
I like this dog, yeah.
- I can tell
- Right.
- Yeah, yep.
- Kenny's a man who really
wants to feel needed
and feel loved.
I noticed you really watching every dog,
and like, trying to have that eye contact
and like that interaction.
- Yeah, he's the first
one, it just hit me.
- I think he makes up for that
by running the social club.
- Hi!
- Because he gets to take care of people.
But I think it's taken a toll
on other facets of his life .
- How you doin? You wanna go for a walk?
- Kenny needs a dog and a
dog needs a man like Kenny.
- He's just got a really good energy
- Just, he's very calm
- and he likes other dogs.
- What do ya think?
- He's so cute .
- He's really nice and social.
- He reminds me of my last dog so much
Yeah, don't you?
- Should we walk with him a little?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, let's walk with him a little.
- You wanna take him down to the grass?
- Stop going so fast, c' mere.
- He's nice and gentle though,
and he's attentive and he's responsive.
- You're so beautiful.
Look at the treats!
- Oh boy
- Hi buddy, how you doin?
You good?
You a good doggy?
Yeah you're a good doggy.
You gonna be my doggy?
We gonna go home?
- Yes !
Have you decided ?
- Yeah!
- That was easy!
That was really easy.
- You and me be buddies?
You gonna come home?
Yeah I'll take care of ya
I'll feed you good, how's that?
- Okay, I'm coming too!
I'll take care of ya
and we take you for walks every night.
I'll take ya.
- Okay, come on let's go home.
- Okay, let's go right?
- Let's go tell the
good news to the ladies.
- Come on.
- We've got puppers who officially,
what have you decided today?
- Fab Five!
- I think it's the best name ever!
- Fab!
- Fab Five, ready to go?
- You excited for your house ?
- Yes
- We got a doggy
- Ohhh.
- You be good you Fab
Five you little baby.
- Bye bye you guys, thank you so much
- Thank you
- What you think Fab?
Hmm.